over the years Google has had some
spectacular failures from Google Glass
and Google+ to Google VR and Google
Nexus but while unfortunate these
failures are what made Google it was
always their willingness to experiment
and shoot for the Moon that created so
many successes along the way whether
that be Chrome Android YouTube or Gmail
but one failure that was unlike the rest
was actually one of their most recent
failures Google stadia if you're not
amiliar with stadia it was Google's
attempt at entering the gaming space and
more specifically the cloud gaming space
the idea was that instead of spending
hundreds of dollars on a console or
thousands of dollars on a PC you could
just stream 4K games directly from
Google you simply pay an upfront fee of
$130 for a starter kit and then a $10
per month subscription afterwards from
the very beginning though stadia didn't
quite live up to Google's expectations
for example in 2020 they were targeting
1 million monthly active users
but they ended up falling short at
750,000 this was nothing to scoff at
though as it gave them a 5 to 10% share
of the entire cloud gaming Market within
just 2 years of launch we should also
mention that Microsoft and Sony's cloud
gaming market shares are largely skewed
to the upside because their offerings
come along with Game Pass ultimate and
PlayStation Plus premium as such a lot
of these subscribers don't even use
Microsoft and Sony's cloud gaming
offerings but they're nonetheless
counted for market share purposes So
within the niche of cloud gaming stadia
was actually doing really well it
garnered some rather strong reviews
despite being a subscription model and
being from Google two things that people
are usually not the biggest fans of and
while it obviously had its issues like
any other new product Gamers were rather
optimistic about the upcoming stadia
exclusives and the cloud gaming space in
general but for whatever reason on
September 29th 2022 Google announced
that they would be shutting down stadia
at the start of 202 3 this was a
direction that even Google's own
internal stadia team wasn't aware of in
fact the stadia team was publicly
assuring users that stadia wasn't going
anywhere just 2 months before this as
such shutting down stadia was very much
an executive decision that was made as
part of a broad effort to cut costs
across the company so here's the story
of the time that Google idiotically
killed a promising
product
taking a look back the story of stadia
takes us back to the beginning of 2018
to a man named Phil Harrison Phil was a
lifelong gaming executive having entered
the industry with his own game Studio
back in 1986 since then he had risen to
be the president of Sony's worldwide
PlayStation Studios and a VP on
Microsoft's Xbox team he also held board
member seats at several gaming companies
so when Google started off 2018 by
hiring Phil as a VP it was clear that
Google was entering the gaming space
they would spend the rest of 2018
attending a bunch of gaming events to
recruit game developers who could make
their ambitious Vision a reality you see
Google wasn't just trying to create a
game streaming service but a game
streaming service that could be run on
Chrome itself and somehow Google's new
Engineers would make this Wizardry
viable by the end of 2018 itself when
they quietly launched a limited beta of
Assassin's Creed Odyssey a couple of
months later in March of 2019 Google
would host a more formal unveiling of
stadum and later that year Google would
officially launch stadia on November
18th 2019 with a total of 22 launch
titles the consensus of the launch was
pretty ubiquitous almost all reviewers
agreed that the technology itself was
nothing short of revolutionary with the
right internet connection stadia truly
did deliver a revolutionary gaming
experience but that was also their
biggest critique you needed the right
internet connection preferably fiber
which most people simply did not have so
while the Tech buying stadia was heavily
praised reviewers were skeptical
regarding whether that Tech was actually
applicable to the average person but
this was nothing unique to stadia this
was the case with every cloud gaming
solution most of which stadia was far
ahead of in every other aspect aside
from some concerns from reviewers there
were also some DieHard Gamers who
weren't the biggest fan of stadia
usually though these were just
enthusiasts with unrealistic
expectations for a brand new Cloud
streaming service like this person who
took the Reddit to rant about how much
stadia sucks they didn't find much
support on Reddit though in fact almost
all of the replies to this thread were
in support of stadia I play almost
exclusively on Chrome maybe I'm just not
as fussy as most people 200 hours in
Borderlands 3 on Chrome I had no idea it
sucked the whole time no it doesn't suck
no issues here whatsoever maybe your
setup internet ISP just sucks I think
this is more of a you problem and not a
chrome problem everything I've played
looks great in Chrome I have no issues
on Chrome weird I've been playing on
Chrome and it's fantastic this isn't to
say that the op didn't have valid
concerns it's basically a certainty that
stadia was inferior to Dedicated gaming
rigs worth thousands of dollars this
however wasn't the target market for
stadia the target market was casual
gamers who were looking for a cheap way
to enjoy decent gaming and that's
exactly what stadia offered and a lot of
people loved it that's why stadia was
able to reach 750,000 monthly active
users by the end of 2020 itself for any
new game company these numbers would
have been insane but for Google they
were rather disappointing leading us
into Google's main dilemma with
stadia if you look at any public
statements Google has made about stadia
you'll immediately see one common thread
just not enough it wasn't that cyia
wasn't profitable or that that the tech
didn't work or that their core users
didn't like it rather it was simply that
everything that stedia had achieved was
simply not enough honestly this is
extremely confusing from Google because
historically they've had to wait several
years if not over a decade before many
of their products became lucrative and a
lot of those products cost a lot more to
maintain like YouTube I mean it's no
surprise that storing billions of hours
of videos for free is extremely
expensive and that's why it took Google
10 to 15 years before YouTube became a
profitable Venture and what about the
pixel Google has been trying to break
into the smartphone market since the
beginning of smartphones yet they still
don't even control 1% of the global
smartphone market not to mention pixels
aren't sold with very big margins so
Google may very well be losing money
with the pixel but they refuse to give
in it's the same thing with Google Fiber
and Google Plus and Google F and Google
meets and Google's Enterprise Cloud
business and several other Google
services while these never quite lived
up to their expectations Google has
given them plenty of time and immense
resources to succeed and it was only
when there was absolutely no way forward
that they finally threw in the towel the
same however cannot be said about stadia
where they almost immediately threw in
the towel when they saw underwhelming
performance and one of the main reasons
for this was that they came in with
extremely unrealistic expectations to be
honest I don't even think their frame of
reference was other streaming services
like GeForce now which has 20 Mill
registered users I mean just take a look
at how Sunder described stadia with
Google your games will be immediately
discoverable by over 2 billion people on
a Chrome browser Chromebooks chomecast
pixel devices and we have plans to
support more browsers and platforms over
time that's in addition to all the
people playing and watching games across
YouTube and Google play so now we have
focused on our next big effort which is
to build a game platform for
everyone and when we say for everyone we
really mean it it's one of our most
cherished values as a company be it
Android or Chrome or AI we are dead
serious about making technology
accessible for everyone hearing that it
seems that Google was hoping to create
something on the scale of the play store
or Android Straight off the bat just
because T was accessible by so many
people you don't have to be a is to see
how that's a rather faulty line of
reasoning just because Google could put
stadia in front of billions of people it
doesn't mean that billions of people
would be interested in reality the cloud
gaming Market is still very much a new
industry that was only worth $1.25
billion in total in 2021 so stadia's
estimated revenue of $76 million
accounted for over 5% of the entire
Market within just 2 years of launch
even if stadia didn't grow their market
share and simply grew with the market
their 5% share may have been worth $2
billion worth of Revenue by 2030 if they
were able to grow to 20 or 25% it may
have been worth closer to $10 billion
worth of Revenue resulting in a business
worth tens of billions for a perspective
that by itself would be a Fortune 500
company but Google wasn't willing to
stick it out which brings me into their
next Pitfall which is that they couldn't
handle being
early people will often tell you that
you want to be early to a market that's
how you get the first mover advantage
and dominate your industry but
ironically Google has never done that
ever all of their most successful
products were either launched in line
with market trends or extremely late in
fact Google was years if not decades
late to search email and browsers as
such every industry they disrupted
already had a massive audience even in
the industries that Google failed like
social media and video conferencing they
never really had a user issue they only
had retention issues with Google+ for
example Google boasted 540 million users
now 90% of sessions didn't even last 5
seconds but again that's a retention
issue not a user issue in basically
every industry that Google has entered
getting users was never really a problem
for them because of their ubiquitous
nature all Google had to do was convince
these people that their Solutions were
Superior sometimes they succeeded in
this sometimes they didn't and they
approached tadia with this exact same
strategy they created a worldclass
solution and put it in front of people
but there was one major difference the
cloud gaming Market was yet to truly
develop meaning that there was no
existing audience to convince rather it
was up to Google to appeal to new users
and create the market and it seems that
this was not a journey that Google was
especially excited to venture down it
because the reality is that being early
is usually way harder than being late so
they decided to pull the plug in an
extremely expensive manner they promised
to refund all stadia Hardware purchases
made through the Google store and all
game and game add-ons purchased through
the stadia store this resulted in
refunds of up to $900 per person instead
of spending all that money on refunds
Google could have just kept stadia alive
and seen how far it took them after all
it's not like the operating expenses for
stadia were really a concern for Google
also it's not like the cloud gaming
Market is suddenly going to stop growing
without Google it'll continue growing
into a substantial market and it'll
probably just be controlled by Microsoft
Sony Nvidia and maybe Nintendo in the
grand scheme of things though I guess it
doesn't really matter because Google is
so big at this point that even another
$20 billion revenue from stadia doesn't
even make a difference but that doesn't
change the fact that what happened to
stadia was still quite a shame and that
is the story of the time that Google
killed a promising product simply due to
unrealistic expectations and a lack of
patience and commitment unlike Google
someone who is adamant on not giving up
on the gaming Market despite terrible
economics is Microsoft who just dived in
even deeper with their $70 billion
acquisition of activis Blizzard check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next
one